[Music]
what if Earth's orbit ventured as far
from the Sun as Pluto and got as close
to it as Venus would humans be able to
survive such extreme changes in
temperature and if we could what are the
chances that earth would follow this
orbit safely through space without
crashing into another planet this is
what F and here's what would happen if
the earth had a large elliptical orbit
the Sun has a stronger gravitational
pull on us than any other body in the
solar system but other planets are
slightly pulling us towards themselves -
that together with the Earth's velocity
makes the planet's orbit elliptical the
difference between the farthest and the
closest point to the Sun in our orbit is
less than five million kilometers that's
nothing compared to the overall distance
of 150 million kilometres from us to the
Sun but what if that distance was much
much greater the Earth orbits the Sun at
just the right distance not so far away
that we turn into an icy Rock and not so
close that we burn to a crisp we are in
the sun's habitable zone where water can
exist in liquid form even the slightest
shift in the Earth's orbit would change
that the closer we got to the Sun the
more heat would hit the planet I think
it would be nice to have summer all year
long everywhere on earth I bet you've
changed your mind pretty fast as the
heat became more extreme all the ice on
the planet would start to melt global
sea levels would rise 70 metres enough
to cover London's Tower Bridge and flood
most of the planet with little land left
to absorb the scorching heat from the
Sun global temperatures would skyrocket
our oceans would begin to evaporate all
this would leave us with a tremendous
amount of carbon dioxide in the air and
little to no water left as we approach
the orbit of Venus the surface
temperature of the earth would go up to
460 degrees being outside would give you
severe burns no matter how much
sunscreen you put on your skin
after getting an incredible suntan on
our vacation near Venus we'd head back
across the solar system all the way to
Pluto the earth would cool down on the
way but it wouldn't matter for most
life-forms on the planet
they wouldn't have survived the extreme
heat maybe if we moved slow enough some
new life-form would evolve on the earth
while it's traveling to the habitable
zone again but that life wouldn't last
too long either
the upcoming winter would be long and
very cold if there was any water left on
earth it would freeze as we reach the
minus 220 degree temperature of Pluto's
orbit if the earth kept moving at the
same speed it does today it would take
about 20 years to make a full orbit from
the hottest spot closest to the Sun to
the coldest edge of our solar system
that is if we didn't collide with any
other planet on the way which isn't all
that unlikely but it is likely that
we'll be making this trip so low the
moon might not be able to handle the
pressure of this extreme orbital journey
lifeless and moonless the earth would at
least get to enjoy some spectacular
views who knows maybe we'd sail too
close to Jupiter and become one of the
moons of the gas giant but that's a
story for another what-if
[Music]